so stuff describe to me and I know a lot
of guys that are single uhhuh I'm being
real okay let's be real for a second
yeah what do you like so I want to know
what you like okay so I'm going to close
my eyes I want to see if I can visualize
it well I how about this imagine I'm
being real stuff imagine you're in the
future and now in the future There's an
actual store you can go to and you can
design like you know the teddy thing
that what's it builda bear build there's
a build a man okay like this is going
yeah and my name is
honzu okay and I own it I'm the Creator
right I'm a huge fan of your this is
you're probably going to be um 65 by
then but let's heck why let's take no
you have me off no you no you have a
time machine anyways I'm Hunter Su okay
right and I go oh it's the big b of your
comedy I can build whatever you want
okay so tell me now
let's height tell me height 6'2 6 or two
holy [__] go to the warehouse get more
flesh okay go chck yeah yeah yeah so
they they're getting more flesh get all
the flesh you know what I mean uh hey
get the Rob granowski prototype okay so
he get the Rob grossing protype right so
um 62 what color cuz we have Min color
I'm any color no you you just build of
human man okay okay okay you can get
whatever I don't want to do random I
like like a light black guy light get
the light skin yeah we only have two
left oh you really popular yeah popular
yeah the curry okay get St Curry Steph
Curry yeah Steph Curry get step C no
more Steph Curry St Curry no more Steph
Cur go darker oh no no uh uh the guy
that got SLA what's his name that's CHR
Rock no no yeah no the Will Smith the
one that's yeah Will Smith oh we haveth
he doesn't know Will Smith this far in
the future I don't why you know sket
Steve McQueen some people don't know
Steve McQueen right right I'm playing a
[__] Sor sketch is real dude it's
based on reality of the SK okay all
right get the one that would slap the
guy Will Smith okay Will Smith so um f I
Like A Defined jaw no double chin no
Chin no double chin no double chin no
yes on chin ch ch Oh I thought no Chin
no no they F we just we could just do
from up Ben affic or yeah no like my
like yes your jawline I want a jawline
we have one jeno left one J very popular
very popular meile we have 20,000
Jen but we're lying we only have one
left J you a
lightskinn and and I'm really buying
this okay yeah get the last one get the
last so far you're describing Scotty
Pippen but keep going okay so the CH
okay now
eyes like big eyes look get the what the
bobbly you want the Bobby
eyes no big eyes big eyes no the Michael
Shannon the one that
oh yeah yeah yeah not bulbus no the ones
that go um diverse no no no put that
away put that away yeah yeah yeah all
right so big eyes get the big the nose
big smaller small cuz I have a big nose
I can't have two beaks clonking around
but we have 50% on
Juno 50%
you sure medium average medium medium
medium nose medium women love big noses
guess what men
don't how about teeth we have a teeth I
don't mind I I can do some crooked teeth
but not no but they have to be clean
floss missing teeth get the brand new
Steve
Bushi oh Bushi 20122 yeah yeah yeah 22
no from back in college 199 get 19 I
want someone to ask actually draw this
person out cuz this sounds insane right
now okay so now we got the we got that
hair that' be very important no we need
hair what kind lots of hair
froo or do it long not long no shorter
shorter but textured murly okay Curly
text te yeah textured so bigy I don't
even know what I'm saying things I like
anymore I'm trying to think of things
that look funny my clown hair yeah put
put a clown wig on them at this point I
got Bui teeth and clown hair Okay so
what the hell's happened now we have a
new feature
Mobility what no because you know
because it cost extra it cost extra you
want so you want somebody like we Carl
You Know Carl Lewis they can run fast or
you want slow what do you need regular
walk regular walk get the regular then
okay it just Factory just comes with it
factory settings factory settings person
personality maybe oh no now we going to
now we're different department now we
got the body right now welcome to the
personality beyond the area okay wait I
get to pick the dick we're skipping over
the dick [__] we forgot go back go back
to we forgot why are we why are we
Jewish now don't I don't know no so we
got um can I be honest with you uhhuh
dick is expensive very expensive at this
store right we get some free another
store and bring it in we don't do that
so we have some free dicks you you know
mostly Asian they're free
I've got some money saved I'll use okay
so forget the freees right so you want
uh who do we have a j two Jason M MOA
left yeah I'll take a m Mo I'll defin
I'll take a John Ham you got a John Ham
we we have a John give me the John Ham
dick feure where we can squirt not Cal
but any any
flavor see you Pineapple what do we got
mango like moo squirt yeah mango we
don't have M mango we have blood orange
no that sounds
bad yeah we have what pomegranate
pomegranate is nice cream you have I'll
do the pomegranate we do p okay the
pomegranate come
quickly quickly because this bit's too
long all right so let's go to the
personality quickly describe describe
okay very funny witty
kriff smart get Woody
Allen no Woody Allen I want some [__]
no no Woody Allen oh no okay no no child
[__] or the hell he did no we take
that component
out we have the ability to take it out I
don't want some guy who want a [__]
stepdaughter whoa wait all that okay
anyway put up away uh who else I know
who uh we got a good